que se passe-t-il tous les ans le 21
juin c'est le jour le plus long c'est
pas mal ouais j'en dise la fête de la
musique j'avais dit voilà j'espère que
vous dites aussi que c'est la journée
mondiale du yoga ce qui nous apprend à
être zen quand nos voisins jour lyxor du
matin exactement
c'est le premier jour de l'été c'est la
fête de la musique c'est la nuit la plus
courte
[Musique]
bienvenue à montpellier et ce soir
célébrons ensemble les 40 ans de la fête
de la musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
descendre dans la rue pour danser
chanter jouer ce qu'on veut comme on
veut
kan ce premier jour de l'été 1982 un
souffle libertaire traverse le pays et
touche toutes les générations
[Musique]
la fête de la musique est lancée presque
décrétée par le ministre de la culture
de l'époque jack lang et ce n'était pas
gagné d'avancé
at langue expédié à la culture et à
l'origine de l'événement était de la
partie
chaque lens il est aussi populaire c'est
parce que elle a été approprié par les
gens eux mêmes cela appartient au corps
gouvernement à personne c'est l'oeuvre
des citoyens de ce pays qu'ils aiment la
musique après deux ans d'enfermement
qu'elle respiration quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait des cigales
et maintenant on fait le chat
les maintiendra quoi
c'est manon nan shan xi galles quatre
chats c'est parti
le ch à
4 cigale
méchas et on accélère et
vous qui accumule les soucis et tracas
souvenez-vous du lion
[Musique]
à
wucher épicier débordés par les clients
submergé par les carottes les pois
cassés et les choux-fleurs n'hésitez pas
[Musique]
faites les pieds au mur dans ma vraie
jodie la posture du lion comme ça au
bureau quand on est un peu stressé ou à
la machine à café on pourrait faire ou
le chien fait en bas qui est très très
simple à tignes c'est un petit navire tu
n'avais jamais vu
et maintenant on va rajouter un petit
truc qui fait
allez-y
si vous y arrivez pas vous soulevez les
commissures prenez vos goûts vos doigts
comme ça
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai ya des points de suture
qui vont lâcher ça ces additions
l'ouverture du leclerc locale le premier
jour du lb ça change des clients
habituels
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire
la question est la suivante sur cette
pochette le monsieur
il porte à droite mushir
[Applaudissements]
al gauche à droite
[Musique]
on en est là vraiment regardé
anton ponty à performer une chanson de
john lennon avec ses mains il a remporté
30 mille dollars il a donc gagné la
version finlandaise de la france adopte
allons regarder
[Musique]
c'étaient les moines qui faisait goûter
les moines tibétains oui asie je vais
essayer ça c'est sale et très dur de
sortir un second conseil c'est très dur
il est musicien
c'est le contraire harmonieux comme
musique mais c'est pas évident en deux
mots ça sert à rien